do you think you're liked as a person
that's a good question that's a very
very good question
and my thing is create a legacy so that
whether they like you or not they
respect you yeah yeah that's what I care
about I don't care if people like me or
not because I'll tell you this there's
plenty of girls that I've had sex with
that didn't like me but they respected
me
because women must respect you to [ __ ]
you yeah
yes I know so why wouldn't you
if I wanted to say because I'm the man
you were attracted to me in the first
place because of my lifestyle I'm not
going to change who I am because of a
woman
when a man changes for a woman he grows
into something she's going to have
consent for when a woman changes for a
man she'll grow into something he'll
love that's how I got you in the first
place why would I change and that's the
biggest mistake that guys make is they
get in a relationship they get
comfortable that's true that's true they
get fat they get less ambitious because
they're like oh I got the woman I should
be comfortable nah she might leave your
ass
she might leave your ass be careful they
lose their ambition our daughter yeah
blah blah blah and that woman starts to
lose what respect for him when a woman
changes for a man he gains more respect
for her men and women are so different
yeah when you're changing for a woman
that inevitably puts her in her
leadership role and when the woman's in
the leadership role she's gonna lead you
all right to them the relationship
that was funny
do you give your partner your phone
password no I want I wouldn't mind I
wouldn't really care
oh I'm not gonna let a girl
why because I'm gonna have other girls
I'd like to keep my
I know everyone's gonna be like girls
keep the wildest [ __ ]
sometimes I write song lyrics and my
notes app
some of them are embarrassing I'd just
rather
I'd just rather eat
I might move to a notebook like an
action you know and I'd be right I'll be
writing like bars you know
freestyles
I don't want anyone looking at that okay
I don't I don't want anyone nobody
that's the only thing that I would
rather not share
100 the thing is is that most of them
can handle the truth so I'm gonna be I'm
very big on like being upfront and
letting her know listen I'm gonna have
other girls whatever it may be but
you're the main one and she's got to
accept that but her looking at my phone
is just going to hurt her feelings so
you want an open relationship yeah open
her mind close on her own okay what
would be more offensive if you look
through his phone and saw that he had
sex with another girl or you looked at
his phone and you saw that he tried and
she denied him that's not fair though
life isn't fair because no I just kind
of feel like the kind of relationship
that I want
isn't that what if I told you women
don't know what they want in general
sometimes most don't some this has been
statistically proven that women don't
know what they want cool and yeah
they're all in cell culture podcast okay
women don't know what they want and
worse yet they're not going to be honest
about what they want because of strict
societal standards where they don't want
to look like hoes yeah because you guys
call women hoes rightfully so not right
you have to
you have to describe it like what else
you gonna describe
foreign
just like be sexually liberated
genuinely why does she have to be a hoe
okay do you want to be at home I don't
really care what you think if you're
going to say I'm home I'm saying no I'm
asking no girl wants to be a hoe wait
let's just be real
I don't really I'm not attacking I'm
asking you this as a question I don't
want to be labeled a hoe for what you
guys paint at Home well let's peel the
layer back do you want to go out and
have sex with a bunch of different men
at the same time why would I want to do
that okay
you want to hear something magical most
women don't want to do that most girls
don't even want to be hoes yet girls
argue and you know debate to be hoes I
don't get it they don't want to be host
we don't but it's just kind of it's just
a double standard we don't want you to
where where
sorry why are we going to cry like I
mean there's a bunch of double standards
that don't benefit I'm just saying I
feel like there's hyper-independence
Liberation like movement is because
we're just sick of men like you that
want to just attack women for being able
to do something that you guys are doing
just as much not attacking but I'm
saying in general like I'm reporting a
fact if a woman is promiscuous she is by
definition to help
around you sleeping around I am a
homemaker
homemaker
you're just an idiot men can't be hoes
okay men okay it's true it's true look
at
um
it's true have sex with a lot of women
are successful in your eyes as men this
is the thing it's like this Brotherhood
thing it's you guys it's you okay okay
let's go back actually I want to see if
we got this one person to come on our
show
uh
what did her team say
I want to see if
and no no we're not going to keep going
back to biology actually
why does he keep going back to biology
we're not in a science lesson
because it mattered matter Cheyenne
she's a perfectly nice lady but it
matters it matters
so what would you do if I was going on
holiday every other month
you'd be single really are we going
together are you going by yourself I
just feel like
I want to go with my man like I want to
go with my boyfriend
trying to think of a situation
where I'd wanna I mean I'd want to hang
out with girls like
but I don't
I just feel like I'd rather travel with
a guy than not
I'm on vacations with my family
but like you can come you know what I
mean oh no you'd be single what would
you do if I couldn't cook
can you cook
no can you cook though I mean can you
fight
that's exactly the last pointless
questions how's that pointless question
you kind of get to know you because
that's your job what's my job to make
sandwiches did he actually just say my
job is to make sandwiches how am I going
to fight off The Intruders if you don't
make sandwiches I need sustenance
you're a dick what would you do if I um
it would never happen how'd you know
that
because no girl is going to match my
ambition or drive I'm quite an ambitious
woman
that's cute but it would never happen
men build the world for real like why is
the goal always about like being on top
firstly well missionaries are fantastic
position first of all and the other
reason why men have to be on top is
because that's the only thing women
respect there's so many people that just
like a nice quiet humble life here's the
thing all women you know what stop
saying Auburn as well okay now that you
said that all women want a guy that's
better than them why'd you get annoyed
and so frustrated about men that are
simps they're giving women that don't
deserve attention and validation
attention and validation messing up for
everybody it's nice when you have men
that are attentive to your needs by you
being successful yeah but let's be
honest we always like the ones that
don't like us why is that
why is that being the man that she wants
in general you're already attentive to
her needs what would you do if your
family didn't like me too bad I've made
you know
my parents trust my judgment and they
would accept it what would you do if I
respect that answer I feel like
your parents can't can only influence
you so so much but it's kind of like if
you pick someone you picked them
a lot of male friends a girl that has a
lot of guy friends is a problem that's a
liability male friends big red flag if a
girl has a bunch of male friends and
she's not willing to give that up to be
with you for the streets women value a
man that has social proof men don't care
about a woman's social proof when you
have friends that's a liability when I
have friends it's social proof it makes
me more attractive it makes you less
attractive what would you do if your
friends were liking my pictures I don't
associate with men that can't attract
women all my friends are good with women
there's a bunch of reasons for this but
you can't hang out with simps you can't
have friends that are thirsty for women
yeah Sims mess everything up but makes
it better for guys like us man we just
come in and
it is what it is we clean up anytime a
woman is the focal of a man's life it's
a problem
100 and the only way a man can give a
woman the best life is when she's not
the focus I don't think so
well that's easy for you to say as a
woman what would you do if I wanted to
start an only fans
you're serious yeah
yeah you'd be single why'd every single
because I'm not going to have my girl
out there on the internet showing her
butthole for 3.99
your girl wants to do only fence bro you
ain't got a girl you got a 304. so the
street she shall return I'm telling you
or else your life is gonna suck but what
if I just wanted to make better money
can't do it uh okay men go to McDonald's
and get a job stop it stop it go go get
a job go get a job I'm so tired of this
narrative this narrative oh as a woman I
had no choice I was a single mother what
about the single fathers they don't do
this
it's like oh I was a single father so I
dealt drugs
your assistant an actual paid assistant
yeah yeah paid by promise you're getting
everything else you get the lifestyle
you're living for free traveling the
world whatever it may be you get the
title of my last name it's a W for you
all the way you get seen in public with
me here's ego
is through the roof
I will say you can tell
Andrew Tate just has a lot more like
game than my like you can just tell
how do you think you're done on the day
this was supposed to be a date yes would
you like me to be more submissive oh my
God hey would that would that make you
feel better it would but it's okay it
was a debate it's fine really so next
time if if you want to date a debate
date so everybody wants to date you she
just has to come being a pick me I mean
giving a man what he wants there's
nothing wrong with that no of course not
yeah
well that's like pretty much it
yeah
um I liked the video I thought that was
funny
um
let's see
yeah
I'm just reading the chat as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible